ici les chiffres que nous allons
découvrir maintenant montre combien nous
sommes tous un jour ou l'autre
directement ou indirectement concerné
par les affaires militaires il ya cinq
cent mille militaires en france dont 300
milles de carrière de 100000 ap auxquels
il faut ajouter également cent mille
civils alors l'armée va être au centre
des débats aujourd'hui avec notamment l'
annonce de mesures par le président de
la république ce soir mais avant de nous
y intéresser on va voir la situation
actuelle est le point de vue des jeunes
sur le service national c'est édifiant
vous allez le voir avec john paul lepers
et jean-françois chevet direction hop à
la 74e régiment le 74e régiment
d'infanterie de belfort
6h05 comme tous les matins le maréchal
des logis contrôler le réveil d appeler
repos dans l'armée les traditions
persiste s'il n'y a plus de clairon il
reste le pliage rigoureux des draps et
surtout la disposition symbolique en
croit les deux canons et la fusée au
milieu 700 jeunes effectuent leur
service militaire dans ce régiment
d'artillerie tous les ans si à première
vue ils se ressemblent tous
il profite de ses dix mois chacun à leur
manière
premier exemple cyril apprentis maîtres
chiens avant l'armée c'était le chômage
j'espère travailler ma passion et sans
l'armée où vous auriez fait quoi alors
dois je serai sans doute rester au
chômage
je suis sûr j'avais pas eu grand
formation j'avais juste un des ventes
pour sedan 1 scolarité a été un échec
on peut encore apprendre à écrire ou à
nager à l'armée au moins on trouve une
occupation
le fier de ça ou pas riche et fière
c'est quelque chose d'important pour
vous la france
bah oui
l'armée reste l'endroit où l'on se fait
des amis mais aussi où l'on apprend à se
fondre dans la masse uniforme c'est
également la bière à cause de l'ennui
moi personnellement un peu
difficile de parler quand on est encore
sous les drapeaux
mais pour ceux qui ont une formation
s'est apprécié le fait d'obtenir
gratuitement un permis de conduire
il aimerait rendre des services plus
concret à la collectivité les hôpitaux
des trucs que je pense qu'on serait plus
utile qui cycle fallon assurent la
dissuasion c'est ce qu'ils nous ont dit
non il y en a certains on peut estimer
qu'ils perdent leur temps parce
qu'effectivement ils tiennent un poste
qui n'est pas à la hauteur de leur
formation
mais ils ne perdent pas leur temps sur
le plan culturel parce qu'effectivement
il rencontre des gens ils font
connaissance de la france depuis des
années le service militaire n'était plus
le ciment républicain qu'il a pu être
aujourd'hui seul un français sur deux
était cus en service comme simple soldat